hello everyone and welcome to the final
game will be showing from the
Grantchester in Paris from the Blitz
event well from the entire event all
together if you don't suggest some some
game that is really enjoyable and I
might have missed it but if that doesn't
happen this will be the last game will
be showing it's the new loop of against
maxime beaugeois graphic seem was
leading understanding so without further
ado and without spoiling too much let's
just enjoy the game
the Sicilian is already on the board
which is not surprising since this did
happen and we have a four by do both now
with c5 the Sicilian defense and now
above doesn't want to test Maxime is
neither off so he goes for Knight to c3
but it's always up to do both to mix the
things up in the opening where these six
and now f4 just grabbing more space in
the center we have g6 Maxime prepares
the finger to the dark square Bishop and
the knight to f3 Bishop to g7 now Bishop
to b5 check Bishop to d7 offering the
exchange and now Russia back to c4
eyeing that nice f7 pawn now we have
nice to see six and mount duo just
castles we have nice the a5 going after
the lights were disappear and Bishop
back all the way to e 2 and here we have
Knight to h6 so there is one game in the
database that reach this position that
continued with the d3 but here Du Bois
wants to get the Queen into the game he
plays Queen to e1 and from there the
Queen can enter the game either via F 2
G 3 or even H 4 so Maxime castles and
now f5 already starting the attack and
here you don't really gain anything by
capturing you can just mess up your bone
structure in front of the King so not
even an option Maxime just further
attack the f5 pawn with East 6 not
threatening the capture here and then if
he captures an f5 denied can recapture
so dubov continues developing with d3
now opening up the dark square Bishop
diagonal not really threatening to
capture you will not be giving up your
bishop for this night he captures an f5
and now as the pawn no longer sorry it
defends the d5 square we have Knight to
d5 just grabbing more space
in the center it's a blitz game so it's
always a good to sacrifice upon for
activity with Bishop to e6 and now
Bishop to F for putting pressure on this
pawn here and now you can see that Queen
g3 followed by the bishop on f4 will be
a lot of pressure against the d6 pawn or
maybe it will not
we've Knight back to c6 by maxime and
Queen to g3 threatening to capture the
pawn here but now FCAT rosani for first
with d captures and Bishop captures on
d5 now with ich after Sun be five and
now before doing anything with the
knight here as the d6 pawn is under
attack first Knight to f5 kicking the
Queen away from this diagonal and only
then will you react to the knight being
attacked
Queen to h3 and now Knight C to D for a
threatening to capture the bishop here
with Czech so Bishop to d3 and now
Knight captures an f3 Maxime is up upon
so why not further trade down with rook
captures on f3 and now Knight to d4
attacking the rook we've looked back to
f2 and now rook to see it getting the
other look into the game also black
wants to play c4 at some point we have
c3 here do buff says your Knight doesn't
really have a square to retreat to you
don't want to go to f5 or I can just
capture there so c4 as planned
so here you don't really gain anything
by capturing if you capture then first
blush of Kafiristan d4 I just will win
material and if you don't want to do
that if you're maybe thinking why not
give up two pieces for a row but then
you can play Bishop C - sure but after
characters and characters Queen b6
really locks your king
you know from escaping if the safeties
are gonna have to play something like
King F 1 then Queen captures here comes
with the threat of capturing the rook
and the bishop you have to play route c1
lock all your Bishop regards the rook
there but it's an ugly position to play
for white even though you have two
pieces for a rook so after c4 with
Bishop back to f1 and now comes Knight
back to f5 and rook to d1 so just
continuing with h5 and now Buster back
to e 2 already here do both has some
ideas of capturing on h5 and then if
black recaptures you can just capture
the knight on f5 so maxime defends
with Bishop 286 and it's a really it's
really deep defense because here if you
go for Bishop captures on h5 Denmark's
team's idea was Bishop captures rook
captures and now Queen the g5 with an
attack against the rook and the bishop
and now after you defend with Queen to
g4 you just trade here and now you get
night to e3 attacking the bishop and the
rook so Bishop captures Knight captures
here Bishop captures on b7 now you go
rook to b8 first better base six now
capture on b2 end after Bishop captures
hear you play Knight captures on c3 and
the meter on the word is equal but you
will have a very hard time keeping an
eye on your a to point so deadly
you know calculation in blitz by maksim
with Bishop to h6 so Daniel captures
with Bishop captures Knight captures on
h6 and now Queen to e3 here dubov says
okay I'm grabbing back my pawn your
knight is under attack and also the pawn
on a7 so maxime defends it with King to
g7 and now Queen captures on a 7
we have Knight to f5 and here while you
could capture on h5 it's not a problem
black will not be able to recapture as
you lose the night here first the dubov
improves the position rugby to f1 and
now Queen to g5 Maxime says ok you're no
longer capturing my pawn but here dubov
has a different idea here he plays he
could he could go for rook to f4 rook to
f4 pretty much eliminates blacks play
here as night to h4 with the main threat
is met with Queen to d4 check and now
you have a double attack against the
night here which just wonders a piece so
it's hard to see what how black could we
have to look to a4 but we have to
remember it's a bullets game so double
goes rook captures on f5 with G captures
and now Queen to d4 check we have King
to h6 and now Bishop captures on c4 so
giving up the exchange so you can mess
up the pawn structure in front of the
black King but also you've eliminated
this very strong c4 pawn now you can
start a pawn storm on the Queen side so
even if you trade on into an endgame you
still have a very strong endgame and
it's always better to you know to have a
bishop and a few extra points in a blaze
game then maybe have a rook or or not
depends on what you prefer rope the GA
maxime forcing white forever keep an eye
on the g2 pawn so rook to f2 and now of
course Queen to c1 will be met with
Bishop to f1 so it's not a problem
we have h4 by black sorry not 84 but
first rook to d8 rook to e8 with ideas
of going Luke to e1 and now we have h4
by dubov just forcing the Queen to move
Queen to g4 and now what do you play
it's Queen to f6 even an option well not
really Queen to f6 here would just
blunder the game because I have to roof
to g6 you either have to go back and
trade Queens where black would have the
upper hand or you can capture on f7 and
then of course you all see how black can
deliver mate here I'll give you a couple
of seconds as it's a nice idea for those
of you who are able to do it
congratulations you are an excellent
mater
in 3 and for those of you who just wanna
enjoy the show rook e1 check of course
you can block with the rook because the
rook has to keep an eye on the G to
point you have to block with the bishop
and then it's the same thing ro captures
on f1 you can't capture with the rook
because of me to have to capture with
the King and then you get rook Queen d1
and this is now mate so you know never
give a check just because you can so
Queen to d2 with check by dubov King to
h7 and now comes the Bishop to d3
threatening Bishop captures an f5 to win
the Queen so maxime defended rookie 5
and now rook to f4 just kicking the
Queen away if you try Queen c2 it's not
a problem yes you bring another attacker
here but king g6 does a nice job then
you can just play rook here look here
and black will prevail so after Luke e5
looked f4 attacking the Queen and now
comes Luke the e1 check here maxime says
okay you grab my rook I'm gonna grab
your rook so of course you have to block
with Bishop to f1 and now comes Queen to
g3 defending the rook on anyone also a
possibility was rookie - it's a very
sneaky idea where you cannot capture the
route because of mate and here you would
have to trade just Queen captures and
Queen captures on f4 leaving black with
a better game but again it is blitz
anything can happen
Queen to g3 and now comes
captures an f5 here look the g7 keeping
an eye on the f7 pawn and now double
plays rook captures on h5 so grabbing
two points in a row with check King g8
and now look back to f5 so here as you
can see dubov has three points 6 points
against three
but Maxime still up the exchange with
Queen captures on h4 now with ideas of
you know creating some pressure along
the H file so look to f3 preparing to
meet any rook to h7 ideas with rook to
h3 but it's not a problem
rook back to e5 now the other route can
come help out with the attack as well we
have Queen to f2 offering a queen trade
but now Queen to h7 preparing the other
group to come to h5 so it's not a
problem and here Google just starts
pushing on the Queen side we have a 4
but now it no longer works here rook to
h5 with the threat of rope to h1 mate
and now of course you have to make some
room for the king queen the d4 displayed
and now when you see this position you
think about rook h1 check do I play this
do I don't play this but then you see
King f2 and then you see Queen to see to
check and this already is enough for
every player to go in to start an attack
especially in a blitz game so of course
the maxime probably calculated it out
much much farther than this but even
this is enough to play rook h1 so this
is what Maxime does look at one check
came to f2 and now Queen the C to check
Bishop to e2 blocking and now how do you
continue again feel free to pause the
video and try to continue this game in
the best possible way for black for
those of you who are able to do it
congratulations you are an excellent
threatener of mate in one
and for those who just won't enjoy the
show Queen to c1 now the thread is Queen
to g1 mate and this is something if you
new to chess it's always good when
you're looking for ideas how to make the
white king if you already have him on
the run for example it's always nice to
remember that if you have like two
pieces one in front of the King one to
the left of the King or to the right
doesn't really matter then for example
Queen the g1 will be made let's even use
another color for this maybe a nice
green one because the
Quinn from for example from here covers
this this line this line and this
diagonal and the only two squares
available for the Kings retreat are the
ones blocked by the pieces of course if
that piece is a knight then the idea
doesn't work because of course the
knight will be guarding the g1 square
here
but if it's any other piece other than
the knight then of course it's made so
you should always look for ideas like
this hope that was helpful rook to e3
making some room for the king but now
you just continue the King hunt with
Queen te one check King to f3 and now
Queen to g3
again with check we have King to e4 and
now you finish the hunt rook to h4 check
queen g6 was also possible but loop to
h4 a much more straightforward move as
white loses the Queen so there is no
point in continuing so here it was in
this position on move 49 that Daniel
dubov resigned and an excellent victory
for maxime beaugeois graph
so maximal in the rapid section and he
really had a terrible as the inlets but
here if you if we check out the
standings after the final day you can
see that overall winner maxime beaugeois
graphic interface with 21 points
followed by Vishwanathan Anand only half
a pointless so once again
Anand chose the youngsters how it's done
and shows the why he is still the best
followed by anypony she a young pony she
faced novice marathon anand in the final
round and had an opponent she won he
would be tied for first place with
Maxime but Anand defeated him and then
we have this well line up as it is
greased shook also had an opportunity to
catch up to Maxime as he also has 20
points but he lost the Fabiana Caruana
in the final round and then he also was
left at 20 points but there we have it
these are the standings followed by
young she stopped do that alpha beyond
Kerwin and Cara Nakamura Schaffner
mamedyarov Daniel do both and onigiri in
last place so there you have it those
were the standings and here an awesome
photo by Justin Keller of all of the
participants of the Grantchester in
Paris here it is let's just enjoy that
it's really a remarkable photo now
someone mentioned on on on Twitter it's
as if it's a cover for a new Netflix
series you know if it if it would be
what would this
the name of this new Netflix series B&O
feel free to you know suggest a name in
the comments but there you have it I
think it was the photo was made before
the actual end of the tournament so I
think it's a coincidence that we have
Maxima in the middle as the winner and
then on to the right as the the second
is internment because to the left
wouldn't be Fabiano it would be Yanni
Pony she so I don't know what's the idea
about the whole setup but I think it was
actually done before the tournament
ended Maxime is maybe in the middle
simply because he's French and the
tournament is played in Paris but but
also it could be and anything else but
yeah that's the game I do hope you
enjoyed it I have a very special game
plan for for today today evening so hope
you will be ready for that it's one like
and you know we haven't seen a game such
as this one before nobody and I would
like to thank Daniel bond a Proctor a
miner and Michael keen for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot - really appreciate it as usual you
can check - on my previous videos here
think of for watching and I will see you
soon continuing the Capablanca saga and
of course checking up on your
suggestions thank you all I will see you
soon and have an excellent rest of your
day